لا تزال معركه ضخمه متواصله حيث ان مصيرها
لم يحسن بعد في ظل زحف الروسي المتواصل
مقابل دفاع اوكراني مستميد في اخر
التطورات اعلن الرئيس منطقه دونيتك
الموالي لروسيا ان التطوية المدينه
الاستراتيجيه بالكامل بات قريبا جدا
فماذا تبقى للقوات الروسيه لمحاصره بخموت
بالكامل بعد تسعه اشهر مشاهدين من القتال
نجحت القوات الروسيه بقياده مجموعه فاجنر
في محاصره المدينه من ثلاث جهات وهي
الشمال الجنوب والشرق وتبقى الجهه الغربيه
الوحيده الصامده لحد الان في وجه القوات
الروسيه والتي تحاول السيطره عليها لتطويق
المدينه بشكل كامل ويحتدم القتال بشكل
اساسي في المنطقه الشماليه والتي تعرف او
تعرف كثافه متزايده لهجمات القوات الروسيه
الباحثه عن زياده الضغط على المنطقه
الغربيه من الشمال هذا وتمكنت القوات
الروسيه من تعقيد عمليه وصول الامدادات
الى الجيش الاوكراني عن طريق قصف الجسر
الذي يربط المدينه
في بلده شازوفيار غربا ورغم الاعتماد على
قوه فاجنر الى ان روسيا استعانت ايضا
بقوات جيشها المنتشره في المنطقه الجنوبيه
القريبه من قريه جروفلوك